now today in out of this world the first  ultra high-def video of Earth  specifically those are the streets of  Boston shot from 35 million dollar  cameras roughly 250 miles away on the  International Space Station it comes  from a vancouver-based company called  Earth cast whose mission is to  democratize the astronauts view of Earth  but why here CEO Scotland if you're  looking for spy stuff this isn't it if  you're looking for humanitarian social  deforestation water management woof sign  groups were signed agreements with  groups like the United Nations and lots  of DeForest and and nonprofits basically  earth cast will stream views of Earth  for free and sell targeted views over  specific periods of time for up to  twenty thousand dollars and the data  could be useful for anyone from  environmentalists watching deforestation  to economists counting cars in a Walmart  parking lot earth casts newest camera  goes live this summer